[Music]
i wanted to be part of the world
but i didn't see anyone like me in it i
hear about a summer camp for the
handicap run by hippies
somebody said you probably all smoke
dope with the counselors and i'm like
sign me up
you have to catch and find yourself
there i was i was in woodstock
you wouldn't be picked to be on the team
back home but
at janet you had to go up the back
even when we were that young we helped
empower each other
it was allowing us to recognize that the
state is quo
is not what it needed to be
the world always wants us dead we live
with that reality
at the time so many kids just like me
were being sent to institutions
it was just a continual struggle most
disabled people
like myself are unable to use public
transportation
we needed a civil rights law of our
hello i'm ann hornaday the washington
post's
chief film critic welcome to washington
post live
and welcome to our oscars spotlight
series
we are highlighting the five films
nominated for academy awards for best
documentary feature
today i'm speaking with nicole noonam
and jim lebrecht
co-directors of [ __ ] camp the disability
revolution
a fascinating film and one of those
nominees
to give a little additional context for
our listening audience today i wanted to
let you know i'm wearing a blue sweater
smudged glasses and i have a small plant
to uh to my left nicole
jim thank you both so much for joining
us and congratulations on the nomination
thank you for having us yeah it's great
to be here
uh [ __ ] camp as you could probably
discern from that
from that clip tells this incredible
story
of uh this amazing camp
that we meet in the 1970s it's older
than that we'll get into the history a
little bit
but the story of this group of people
who went to this camp in the 70s and how
that community
blossomed into what we know of as the
disability rights movement nicole you've
been making
non-fiction films for 25 years you of
course you made the rape of europa
about the theft and destruction of
european works of art during world war
ii you've made a film about
children in calcutta seizing their own
futures
what drew you to the disability rights
movement or did it draw you
kind of both you know i mean i had been
um colleagues with jim
for 15 years and friends and um
and over that time jim had really opened
up this sort of
portal for me into disability and a way
of looking at this ability that i hadn't
before known i saw it as a culture as a
community
jim i would come in to mix a film with
jim uh he's a you know brilliant sound
mixer in the bay area and all the
documentary filmmakers here
you know cherish the time when we get to
bring our films into his studio
and he would be you know playing um you
know an album by a disabled rapper and
he would be talking to me about his
struggle to
um to get access to say the filmmaker's
lodge at the sundance festival which
used to be up you know several flights
of stairs and
i was really fascinated by this more
rights-based way of looking at
disability um so
then i got lucky enough one day for that
jim decided to pitch
me on um you know trying to make
films about disability from that point
of view and films that would
authentically relay experience and he
pitched me
the idea of a film about his summer camp
um and
i kind of rolled my eyes because it
sounded sort of like a cute idea
and like that kind of thing that people
people always feel their summer camp was
special you know
and then he sent me some pictures of
camp genette and i
literally almost fell out of my chair
because i realized that
jeanette was this utopia as jim
described it
that you know was the kind of thing that
most of us have never even known existed
and it still doesn't exist today you
know um so the fact that he was saying
this may be connected to the civil
rights movement this profound experience
of liberation that i and
my friends had um was really intriguing
and
rather than me take on the project i
said to jim why don't we
direct this together so the story can be
told from your point of view
and we set about trying to figure out
how
brilliant and liberation is exactly the
word this
the the imagery the sheer wealth of
images that you had to work with i
thought was just
breathtaking i want our audience to see
a clip sooner rather than later because
in order to get to that sense of joy and
an immense
freedom that that that camp gennad um
offered to its campers is is really
contagious
let's play a clip that that kind of gets
to how magical this place was and then
jim i'd like to circle back with you
i mean when woodstock was happening i
remember being at my grandmother's
listening on the transistor radio
and saying wish i could go wish i could
go wish i could go
and then when i went to jeanette it was
like
there i was i was in woodstock
the music and the people i just feel
like
these people are crazy you know i mean
in a good way
a girl at camp hope to caption it and
find yourself
a boy slides out of his wheelchair into
a pool then he dives underwater amid
other swimmers and those floating in
life jackets
past camper denise jacobson recounts
[Music]
subtitles read it was so funky
but it was a utopia
when we were there
there was no outside world
a black and white camp photo shows
denise as an 18 year old beaming at the
camera from her wheelchair
[Music]
you know it's stunning to think that
this was a camp that was founded
as far back as 1951. jim could you give
us a little history of camp gen ed and
the ethos
behind what as one of the campers
described what became a utopia
the camp back then was started by two
sisters
um and there was just kind of a history
of trying to have a camp that was a
a bit different a bit more open a bit
less restrictive
and certainly when i got there in the
early 70s
indeed it was uh truly was
what what denise said is a a utopia
i i had a sense of freedom there uh
and acceptance and joy that i
rarely ever had outside of that camp
i can't imagine actually that i i really
really really did but it was a product
of its time
it was the early 70s we were questioning
everything all these different
liberation movements
and um you know why not us
right and it you know i think one of the
most um
profound things that this film advances
is this the importance of community and
social space
right i mean i think that so many you
know
one of the definitions of privilege is
that you claim social you know social
space is yours for the taking it's not
even
questioned and this movie just
shows us in such concrete ways how um
having a social space that you can claim
for your own
is just absolutely essential in terms of
personal development and political
development one of the
campers there happened to be judy
heumann of course who's now very well
known
as a disability rights activist um
and one thing the other thing that
something she points out but that this
film expresses beautifully is the
organic intersectionality of the
disability rights movement
um to use a term that we would use today
but maybe not so much then but nicole
how do you
how critical do you think
intersectionality was to the success of
the disability rights movement
i mean what we found was that it was
completely essential
like the the you know the most striking
example of that in the film which is
is actually literal is that the black
panthers delivered food to the
organizers you know who were
um who were sitting in this federal
building you know for
um about a month um every single day
three hot meals a day and um
and they could not have sustained their
protest
and pushed forward you know one the
implementation of the first really
significant disability civil rights
legislation in this country
had that food not been delivered but not
only that folks from the lgbtq movement
folks from the women's movement um all
these different
people who had members who were in the
building
of their own communities because
disability is by its very nature
intersectional
um we're contributing to the success of
this and i think that we felt that that
was a really valuable lesson for the
particular time that we find ourselves
in and
you know as the pandemic happened and
then you know we saw the upswell
of the black lives matter movement this
summer um
it seemed you know like sort of striking
that this story from 1977 was kind of
meeting our moment of today in such a
powerful way but we really felt like
that was true that you can see that
the seeds of this kind of community
across difference
that's created at the camp and then how
that very philosophy and kind of
um you know way of being became the kind
of
you know uh secret weapon or or really
power that um that provoked political
change
down the road
that's fascinating um the protest that
you're alluding to was this incredible
occupation of a federal
building in san francisco which lasted
for 25 days
150 activists occupied the building i
think it's still
this day the longest occupation of a
federal building
um a sit-in at a federal building
i want to play a clip and then come back
to jim who was
who was there who was actually a
participant but let's watch
um a clip that shows how that protest
began
blind african-american activist dennis
phillips recounts
i was asked to go to the demonstration
by my sister and i said okay
i'll give it a shot and then all of a
sudden
someone said well let's go in the
building you know what are we going to
do stand outside
so i headed toward the building holland
the speeches were over and i followed
this
group of people into the building there
must have been 300 people
and they went up to the fourth floor and
they wanted the office of the regional
director
now what's he going to do with all these
people in wheelchairs
judy sits with health education and
welfare regional director joseph
maldonado
we are not asking you anything
unreasonable we are asking you to
request
a telephone call to talk to joseph
califano
mr labassi the general counsel for hew
has been designated as a person
that i should discuss these matters with
and if you can the more i sat in this
room and got these
absolute non-answers the angrier i got
and that's when people started really
feeling like
we couldn't leave because no one knew
what we were talking about but we knew
that they were trying to rescind the
regulation
dennis recounts five or six o'clock came
and nobody was leaving
so i figured okay we're gonna have to
spend the night
so jim put us in the room you were there
at that protest tell us how it all began
and what it was what your memories are
from that time
well i really wish i could say i was
there but actually i
i wasn't i was in college in san diego
kind of blithely
not knowing that this was happening but
i must tell you
that i learned so much about this
particular event
by the work that we did on our film and
and to talk to dennis phillips and a
taunto
corbetto tool and to really hear what
their experiences were and of course
judy and other folks i
i wish i had been there
well you know that brings up a really
good one of my questions is which
is just this wealth of footage that you
had to work with
how did jim how did you assemble um
these images
i i am so gratified and grateful of all
that for all the home movies that were
taken at camp gennad
those are really special but then you
have all of this fabulous footage from
other events
can you tell us a little bit about that
journey
certainly i mean when we first started
out
we did not know that that black and
white video footage
from camp genette existed and it uh i
had this
memory of this group of hippie
videographers showing up at camp
and then in fact one day they handed me
the camera and i i did a tour of the
camp
um with a little bit of information
nicole
set out to try to see if he could figure
out who these people were
and you know lo and behold after three
months of searching
nicole found uh in the back of a
digitized magazine for video makers at
the time
uh an advertisement for a videotape of
the crab
epidemic at campground for the
handicapped by the people's video
theater
and at that point we had a name of an
organization
uh we found that one of them
howard gutstad uh just lived across the
bay in san francisco
and we um wound up being able to uh
leave a message for him
he was a board member at a anarchist
bookstore
in san francisco which is all makes
sense to me
and uh and i we both remember this day
where we got this email
and he said yeah we have this footage
and we've got five and a half hours of
it
and uh that was extraordinary i mean
um the other especially the footage from
the
sit-in is really due to all of us
digging around
finding things we had some incredible
archival
um research people and but we all dug in
to really try to find uh this footage
much of it
uh was very hard to find and we and as
you can
kind of see we had to piece together
oh well and you know you remind me when
we were
we were looking at the [ __ ] camp poster
waiting for this
session to start and i think it it has
the distinction of being rated r
to which you're you're the crab epidemic
the great crab epidemic of whatever year
it was
a test
it's a real it's a badge of courage sir
nicole this documentary is is a
production of higher ground
of course which is barack obama and
michelle obama's production company with
netflix
um and i understand this is one of the
first projects that they signed on for
can you tell us a little bit about their
involvement
yeah i think it actually was the first
um
it was incredible actually so we have
this executive producer howard gertler
and he
uh read in the trades that the obamas
were starting a production company
in partnership with netflix and he
immediately thought because we were
really early on in our process we had
the story mapped out and we had a
fundraising trailer and we were finding
footage and starting to assemble it
you know he thought this could be
perfect for them because of the sort of
shared values
between the obamas and you know our
project
this idea of the importance of
grassroots organizing
the capacity for young people to change
the world you know
um the idea that this is elevating a
story from a marginalized community that
needs to be told and even that idea of
kind of like becoming and telling your
own story
um all of those things are embodied in
our project so we made an effort to get
our fundraising trailer in front of
priya swami nathan who had just been
hired to
run higher ground she called us up and
said i don't know what you guys did but
i cannot stop watching this thing and my
bosses feel the same way
so eventually you know they said they
wanted to roll up their sleeves and
partner with us
and it has really been an incredibly
rewarding partnership
and that they were you know fully
engaged in the process
incredibly supportive of our vision um
gave us a lot of artistic leeway but
actually also gave us a lot of advice
and um
you know president obama and mrs obama
themselves watched
you know three cuts of our family gave
feedback and um you know we
we actually like i don't think that
we've still um
fully internalized that this is actually
happening or has happened but it's been
an incredible
platform um from which to kind of you
know
tell this story which is such an
important important american story i
think one of the great civil rights
stories of our history but that for so
long has remained relatively unknown
you know i was going to say the same
thing this is a buried history and it's
so interesting to me
that it's it's at the oscars this year
alongside
movies like trial of chicago 7 and judas
and the black messiah
that also get especially judas and the
black messiah gets to that same
intersectionality
that fred hampton was practicing before
his life was
ended prematurely so it's just it's
fascinating to me that we sort of get
what we need
in this kind of generational way
sometimes from the culture
um and like you said earlier who would
have known that these would have been
hap you know
brought to us in the year of pandemic
and the in the year of
um protests on behalf of black lives so
i hope that the viewers will take these
these lessons to heart
but i i must ask though both michelle
obama and barack obama are such
gifted storytellers in their own right
can you share some of their notes to you
i mean do you remember any specific
feedback or advice that they gave i'd be
fascinated to hear that
i think that they were they were really
um interested in sort of like the
um the the president obama himself was
really interested in
in the process of how did the how did
the actual
uh legislation come about you know and
had
it was very hard for us to figure out
how to tell this really complicated kind
of
story about how does a movement push
legislation forward
um in a way that was really digestible
but also really historically accurate
so insightful questions that kind of got
us to the place of being able to do that
effectively and also just like
lots of really thought-provoking
questions about kind of um
you know the the camp itself and what
was the philosophy of the camp you know
i think we had
we had at one point thought that we
didn't need to have the camp director's
voice
necessarily in the camp kind of laying
out the camp philosophy and
um you know he we we actually you know
larry allison who started the camp is
not alive anymore so it seemed almost
impossible and it was this kind of like
gentle questioning that kind of
pushed us to figure out you know some
way to do it and we ended up being able
to use this
old audio recording and um and spliced
together
you know it was it was like a just like
an editing feat that kind of
you know if president obama wants it
then we we will make it happen
you know so i'm so grateful that we
actually figured out some way to have
larry's voice
it works beautifully so jim this is in
many ways your life story i mean it
really does
chronicle your your development from a
little boy to the
gifted sound designer that you are today
so you are both you're a character in
this film and you're the co-director so
was the was that ever awkward for you or
uh thread us through that journey for
you
well first off you know i was uh
uh surprised but incredibly happy that
nicole asked me
to co-direct co-produce the film
with her um and um
you know it's really it i i think that
it worked because
we had this incredible um collaboration
we had known each other for a long time
but there was a lot of trust and i had
to put on different hats
at time and kind of just digging and and
really trying not to filter myself
as i was trying to relate stories and
such but there was this trust
that that i could say anything and then
if i felt like i
there was something that made me very
uncomfortable that i
you know we we would talk about it so i
uh you know the trust and support of
everybody
um really made a big difference
yeah and i would imagine too another
thing i really admire about this and i
and i would i would assume that you tell
me um that one of the challenges is
tone you know because it's this is
definitely
an inspiring story but i even think
somebody in the film uses the term
inspiring or inspiration porn you know
you don't want to
you don't want to teeter into being
patronizing um
or condescending and and so can you tell
us a little bit about those
conversations
well i mean that you know the title
itself
is something that we you know we chose
[ __ ] camp oh my gosh
you're using the you know the the c word
and in reality it was
a way first very quickly to kind of say
look this is not your average
ah what an incredible inspiring story
this is a story about a people and a
culture
and a movement and that you know for me
as somebody with a disability not
everybody likes
this term but for me it represents the
fact that i
identify culturally as somebody with a
disability and politically
and and it is words that i you know i've
heard i remember corbett
who you see in the film saying to me hey
jim did you go to [ __ ] camp
and it was like it was the first time i
kind of heard somebody use it in that
in that way and i went oh oh yeah but of
course
and you know when my wife sarah who's
one of our producers
and i were driving around and i go let's
go up one more block because
there's a [ __ ] spot on the right side up
ahead that's a handicapped parking spot
i i wanna just add that you know this
issue that you raised it was
probably the most um important thing for
us to get right
in the film and we we kind of ended up
talking about how there were like these
two
sort of tractor runs that people's
brains go into around disability
and one of them is the inspiring thing
and the other is a tragic thing
so something like willowbrook you know
this horrible institution in new york
state
um from which a bunch of camp genetian
uh campers
uh came and and which jim remembers kind
of being haunted by
having seen geraldo rivera's expose
about it in the 70s
you know how could we put that in there
without it kind of ruining
the feeling that we had were
painstakingly creating
which was allowing people to come into
camp gennad and not ever feel
any of those feelings that people are
almost uniquely used to feeling when
they see disability represented in the
media
you know and so we had a couple of ways
of working on it one was
something called the spirit of steve
which was this sort of punk attitude of
steve hoffman one of the characters in
the film and we just asked ourselves
does every scene have that kind of
punk like sort of fpfu
you know um i'm gonna be the way i am
kind of attitude that was one
one thing and the other thing was just
like really layering a complexity of
emotion in every scene
you know not allowing any scene to be
kind of one pure emotion because if you
did that
sure enough we would have test
screenings and we would see audiences
kind of slipping into that way of seeing
disability
fascinating and by the way steve is the
other source of the r rating here and
i'll leave you with that tantalizing uh
little teaser
uh fascinating character just a
wonderful wonderful protagonist
among many in this film i want to at
least get to
we're coming against time here but i
want to get to an audience question this
is from
rena strober of california and this is
for jim um
jim who makes his who's who's become
like
as we have said a really accomplished
sound designer especially in the theater
she asks how can theater specifically
become more inclusive of those with
disabilities
oh that's a really wonderful question i
look i think that we've seen
non-traditional casting happen in the
past
um where um
[Music]
and i think this needs to be extended
towards actors with disabilities
but also the infrastructure needs to
change wouldn't it be great if this
trillion to three trillion dollar uh
package that president biden is uh
pushing forward now
included some money to renovate theaters
so people with disabilities can
easily be on stage and work behind the
set
behind backstage also i mean
there are people with disabilities who
are capable
and able to work in the entertainment
business but we're being held back by
stigma
and um and lack of access and
you know you'll see more authentic films
and
theater projects like [ __ ] camp if
um our industries really uh embraced us
and applied the same diversity and
inclusion efforts that they have for
other people
well you know that gets to something
that that really struck home with me
watching it which is that
you know most of this is the largest i
don't want to even use the word minority
group but this is the largest group in
the country
um and we're all most of us
are going to be a member of that group
in some fashion in terms of
natural limitations um and so
as we've seen with the americans with
disabilities act those reforms
helped us all and we're grateful for
those every day
um so nicole specifically oh go ahead
jim
but don't frame it as limitations it is
a natural progression in life
and my gosh so many of us think that
this is our special power
you know i i have to improvise almost
every day and i'm not the only one
all of us do so so you know let's frame
it not as this
medical depo decline but this evolution
of who we are as people
and it and it can be a beautiful thing
and an enlightening thing for so many
people
very well said and and the fact that
this did come out in pandemic here
nicole where where accessibility in many
ways
through things like zoom like what we're
doing today you know it has opened up
accessibilities to to some programs to
more people so
i don't know nicole can you speak to
that briefly before we have to say
goodbye but um
do you think people's consciousnesses
have been lifted a little bit over the
last year
yeah i do and i'm happy that [ __ ] camp
has been able to be kind of a part of
that cultural conversation
i think that um you know people with
disabilities have seen
suddenly things that that people folks
have been being told for years where it
wasn't possible for a class a college
class for example
or a meeting or working from home you
know to be to
to be done and all of a sudden because
of the pandemic and everybody needs it
it's possible and i think that the hope
is that
there's been um enough learning about
the importance of accessibility
that those things won't be taken away
you know as vaccinations ramp up
and things get back to quote-unquote
normal you know but that we will have
realized the importance of
making these kinds of accommodations
around accessibility
in order for our workplaces our
communities etc to be truly inclusive
and
um and actually our impact uh producer
andrea levant
and um and stacy park milburn two
brilliant um
young disabled activists out of the
disability justice movement
created a virtual trip camp experience
um at the very beginning of the pandemic
that 10 000 people from all over the
world joined in it was a weekly summer
camp all summer for 16
sundays that really did have a lot of
the elements of the community of camp
genette
and actually built capacity for the
disability rights movement in the middle
of the pandemic and now is being kind of
audited as an example of how you can
make
a virtual environment environment really
inclusive so
um it is an exciting conversation and i
just hope we don't forget the
the learnings that we had this this year
indeed well that's it uh an optimistic
note to end on i want to thank both of
you so very much for joining us today
and for
for helping introduce our audience to
[ __ ] camp